you see I think prestige I think
prestigious I think prestigious I think
wine I think wine I think it's time to
think the sponsor of this video like I
would did that this video is brought to
you by bright cellars bright cellars is
a monthly wine subscription that uses a
seven question quiz to pair you with
your wines based on your taste yeah I
like me a nice glass of red some cabs
some more love me one thing you might
know about me is I'm a self-proclaimed
creature of habit so I'm glad that
bright cellars uses a quiz to pair me
with wines and help me get out of my
routine after you take your quiz that
list out your six wines you can swap out
the ones you may or may not want to keep
then bright cellars send you your box of
six wines no need to even leave your
house it also comes with cars with
information about the wines tasting
notes suggested pairings serving
temperature for the connoisseur and you
otherwise that got suggested to me my
personal favorite was the happy medium
surprisingly light not too sharp nice
and smooth like glass of wine in the
bubble bath kind of smooth you don't
know everything about me and bright
cellars is offering you 50% off your
first six bottle box so click the link
below take the quiz get started and
thank you very much to Brett Sellars for
sponsoring this video it really helps
out I appreciate that and now we review
a movie that's very requested on my
channel like in the history of my
channel I'm actually surprised I haven't
reviewed it sooner prestige
[Music]
the prestige so the procedure was
written by Jonathan Nolan and
Christopher Nolan directed by
Christopher Nolan just came out after
Batman Begins between Batman Begins and
Dark Knight's of 2007 I believe it was
and just like you had to choose because
the prestige and the illusionist came
out or within a month of each other it
was like alright prestige or illusionist
choose I can go about this video one or
two ways I can go the spoiler free
review route or the spoiler route where
I talk about the spoilers and how great
they are I'm gonna go the spoiler free
route because I would rather entice
people who haven't seen the prestige to
watch the prestige because of this video
if you haven't seen the prestige that's
a shame to possibly fix that crying jinx
like when people are like I've never
seen Breaking Bad I'm like I envy you
you get to see Breaking Bad for the
first time that's amazing same with the
prestige if you look at the prestige at
face value and face value alone it's a
very engaging movie about rival
magicians it takes place at the end of
the 19th century these two up-and-coming
magicians played by Hugh Jackman and
Christian Bale they briefly worked
together until tragedy really just now
they're at odds and you know I love me a
good movie about rivalry and conflict
this is one of them just looking at it
from that capacity the tension between
these two one goes after the other the
other goes after the other it's just
it's escalation so where's the conflict
between the two magicians that keeps me
engaged but really it's the
craftsmanship of those movies this movie
is a magic trick it's a cinematic magic
trick you'll know what I mean when you
see it if you haven't seen it yet but
it's a wonderful parallel of how this
movie is executed and the theme in which
it's telling the story but there are
parallels among the characters like
Tesla's in this movie played by David
Bowie who's just like Dark Horse of a
scene stealer this movie touches on the
Tesla Edison rivalry and dynamic right
some would call it that other call it
Tesla getting royally [ __ ] but that
Tesla Edison dynamic is a great parallel
to the dynamic between Christian Bale
and Hugh Jackman's characters in this
movie it's just it speaks to the fact
that the prestige is a case of waste not
details matter in the prestige and you
look at it I don't know what one could
change even the things that might not
feel like they're flowing upon first
watch you go back and watch it it's
important stuff it's really hard to talk
about the prestige and keep it vague
with no spoilers this is a well-crafted
engaging character piece about ambition
and the dangers of it the line between
ambition and being consumed by something
and just the pain and destruction you
leave in the wake and what it can do to
you how it can turn you but also even if
you're not a [ __ ] if your intentions
are more pure than say the [ __ ] in
the story people still get caught in the
wake of your love for your craft and
your ambition so really where is the
line there but obviously there is a line
but it's all the same to the collateral
damage to the people who get caught up
into hurricanes of other people's
ambitions even to this day when i watch
the movie i'm always like it's that Hugh
Jackman like Hugh Jackman plays a double
his character needs a double for a trick
you know you need someone who looks like
the magician this guy's the complete
belligerent drunk ever when I first saw
it I was like yeah he just he looks
different enough but the same it just
kind of blew my mind when I first saw it
I didn't know I didn't know if that was
actually Hugh Jackman or not which
really Hugh Jackman is great in the
movie but his performance has this
drunken [ __ ] that's the best really
the prestige kind of reminds me of James
Cameron's the abyss though nothing like
the abyss in terms of plot what I'm
saying is you look at James Cameron and
Christopher Nolan both are they're
craftsmen of imagination when it comes
to cinema you look at James camera it's
like aliens Terminator 2 avatar because
it broke all this box-office rocker is
technologically speaking however in
there is the abyss which is low-key one
of Cameron's best movies that's kind of
how the prestige is for Christopher
Nolan Christopher Nolan has made movies
out there that cast a much bigger shadow
than the prestige so they get all the
talk and all the chatter but in there is
this movie that's low-key one of Nolan's
best movies the last act of this movie
has what a few Christopher Nolan movies
have where it's like I'm asking you to
take a leap and now we've hit that phase
where I just got an Indiana Jones it and
be like all right sure which I'm fine
with the movie asking me to take one
leap and this movie definitely does but
it all it works out because if you take
Nolan's hand and you go with him on this
leap he will lead you to an ending that
is it's an amazing ending the
- this movie just gets me every time you
know it's when I see the end I'm like
and that's one of the better endings out
there than the best and it's one of
those movies when you watch it you're
like I need to watch that again just
logistically speaking I should got to go
back notice things I didn't notice
before and when you watch it a second
time and a third time and a fourth time
you will notice new stuff every time but
when I went back to watch this movie a
second time the day after I watched it
the first time I never felt like it was
homework I just watched it again because
I wanted to watch it again I was just
along for the ride for the second time
maybe I'm just reminiscing because that
was before YouTube but now when I watch
a movie a second time it's usually
because I got to do a spoiler video and
so my brain is in that mode it's been so
long since I went back and watched a
movie because oh the prestige is it's
like the gold standard of a movie I did
that with it's like no no I just watched
it again because it's gonna did it with
the Dark Knight - but it's just I wasn't
expecting to do it with the prestige the
dark metals like if they pull off Joker
I'm watching this three times in a
weekend and I did prestige was just not
on my radar to be that thing I was just
like double rival magicians I say we
watch it again I'm gonna watch it again
and the prestige is awesome tacular
[Music]
it kind of pained me to be this vague
about this movie so if you haven't seen
the prestige yet please do it I did this
review for you all right so the prestige
have you seen it why did you think about
it or the abyss either whatever you
think of um comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more see I think
prestige I think prestigious I think
prestigious I think wine I think wine I
think is 7/6 fun you see I think person
you see it you see but in the end as
Michael Caine says you're not really
looking because you want to be fooled